More lights,
flash photography isn't prohibited and there was a zero tolerance policy for any
delay or disruption.
Rubin
report,
Internet
credible
Jordan shoes is backstage.
You're warming up.
Are you guys right now?
He is wrestling the 800 pound lobster.
The shit out of that thing in preparation for you guys.
I'm very excited to be here.
San Francisco.
I was actually here a couple of weeks ago.
I was in San Francisco.
I spoke at Berkeley.
Real
higher one.
I have no idea.
I spoke at Berkeley and then I came to San Francisco for dinner and some of you
probably saw this on twitter.
Our car got broken into while we were here and I tweeted out a picture of the
broken glass by our car and literally putting it into.
People were telling me all fucking idiot.
You don't leave a car out on the street in San Francisco.
Excuse.
It's a progressive
value.
Then of course people were telling me that,
uh,
you got to watch out for the,
the human food that you know about this.
You guys have the accurate.
There's actually an act.
And I don't want to tell you who,
but somebody under your chair right now to be watching out for something.
Uh,
this is very exciting.
We've been doing this for a,
this is probably our eighth or ninth show and it's just an unbelievable seeing.
See if you guys.
I do prepare you though that I was actually not Jordan's first choice to open
the tour.
That was Kathy Newman
for Kathy.
I don't want to make it about people.
It's about ideas.
Naturally.
Jordan,
I email her.
I emailed her and said,
hey,
Kathy.
And Angst of going out on tour 12 rules for life.
Very excited to be like to open for me on the tour.
Money's pretty good.
If you want to join me on a tour at Cathy wrote back and said,
so you're saying you want to sleep with him?
There is something really cool going on.
A Nice reminder right before we started.
So did you guys see the uh,
yesterday?
That's really awesome that we're here tonight because you wouldn't actually born
right here in the masonic about six months ago.
Sam Harris is here and we're here hearing arrogant,
one who came up with the phrase on this very stage and this thing,
read this thing that you guys are a part of it that the world is now finally
catching up on that it is real and it's hearing this diversity of people.
We all know there's the diversity that the left glove,
your coloring or gender,
your sensuality and all that nonsense,
and then there's real diversity,
so we've got Sam on the left and on the right and now we have our new leader.
Kanye West.
Are you guys,
biologists and neuroscientists and all these people that have been working on
this stuff like taking this shit.
It's pretty awesome.
Yeah.
There really is some sort of revolution
and the beauty of this revolution,
that's how it happen.
That's okay
in this area.
It's just unbelievable what's going on here.
All of these people coming together.
There's a couple of weeks ago I had A.
I had John Casick.
I might see that
it was raining in La.
It never rains in la and I told them dirty clothes from Ohio farmland down
there.
I've got chickens in my backyard and I do a little chicken coop
in the back of my house because it was raining and couldn't see the cool from
the back window,
so he just decides to walk right into my bedroom.
Empty.
You spend a certain amount of time with Jordan leaders in your bedroom?
Pretty clean.
Okay.
Constantly at the hotel today.
I
cleaned her room.
We had just come back from my room was a disaster.
I just don't my bag out there was stuff everywhere.
PC literally jumps over all my crap all over the floor.
He's staring out the window looking at my dad and I realize that there's a big
bag of weed on my night.
I thought I was going to get more bloated or
kinda
friendly
hanging out with all these fingers.
The last thing I want to do is to
shut my brain off.
That would be better.
Are you almost ready for Jordan?
So when we started this tour,
we,
I said we'd done about eight or nine these.
And uh,
when we,
when we kicked this off,
something really cool guy and I think I'm going to do this and I think it sums
up exactly what's going on here.
And you guys are absolutely.
You were actually in the part.
So some people by the name of the measurable Man
Right at the beginning of the show,
he took a picture with him and his girlfriend and he sent his tweet.
He said,
it's wild to be sitting in a soul down the with thousands of other people
waiting.
Listen with Jordan Peterson and went in my daily life.
I act like a secret tip toe around mentioning Jordan Peterson.
You guys look around.
We are doing,
we are building this thing.
I know you're just beginning yesterday,
there was a lot of rocket fuel behind this thing with.
How about Special Ed?
Ladies and gentlemen in the intellectual dark web has made town introduce the
musical style.
Thanks Jordan Peterson.
Thank
you for
them.
Thank
you.
We have the most elaborate costume.
Thank
God.
I can tell you one thing that I do really like guideline right from the
beginning.
Whatever.
There's been something humorous associated with what I've been doing online and
that's a really good thing.
This is comedy that goes along with this because for them to be a comic on your
toe to anything beats that it's gone.
At least some degree health,
you know,
it's not taking itself too seriously.
The see people who've gone through courbet shirts on steam
and vertebrates
the intellectual level of discourse.
So I have a little story to tell you.
Something kind of Nice to be today.
It's probably more relevant to me because I'm a Canadian,
but there's a magazine in Canada called Maclean's and they ran a club,
a hit piece on it about three months ago.
A woman named Tabitha Southey wrote,
attend.
She's got quite an ambitious woman and she can coin a phrase.
I think he called me the stupid person,
smart person that has been better than the stupid person's stupid person I
suppose.
But that phrase has been bandied around on the internet sort of Ad Nauseum in
subsets in the system.
But today,
and this was.
This was what was cool because there's been an attempt I would say,
by the people who aren't very fun to me too is to attempt to politicize what I
attempted to do some justification for that I suppose because I have been going
after the radical leftists with a fair bit of seriousness,
but I think because they jumped the political but they started to tread in
water.
It started to trend the territory that had no business being politicized with
restrictions on free speech in particular,
but I don't regard what I'm trying to do is particularly political and I think
that's partly because I've known fundamentally a political figure.
I'm fundamentally a clinical psychologist with a secondary identity as a
university professor or perhaps those identities convenient flight.
It doesn't really matter.
It's part and parcel of the same thing as far as I'm concerned.
What I've been focused on in my private practice as an educator is trying to
disseminate psychological information of the highest caliber to individuals
because that's where clinical psychologists do.
We work with individuals because I think the individuals,
the right level of analysis,
you know,
when I come out and see a crowd like this,
I don't see the crowd,
which is partly why I'm actually not afraid of the crowd because I see a bunch
of individuals and you're sitting here and when I talked to the crowd,
I don't talk to the crowd,
either,
won't talk to people in the crowd.
And so Mcclain's,
which is the magazine that published this piece,
satirical piece on me a few months ago,
we actually took the time to send a reporter out to a group that had been
established in Toronto,
which was a Jordan Peterson meetup group.
I guess.
Essentially it's about 50 people or so it would meet up regularly.
They actually sent a reporter out to find out what these reprobates interruptive
and um,
you know,
if you paid attention to the corner of the journalism world,
that is not very happy with my existence.
You would assume that it would be an asset of,
all right.
Essentially all male,
all angry old white because of course that's how the radical left characterized
as people,
right?
They characterize them by gender and race into everything becomes politicized in
that map,
which I think is absolutely contemptible,
but it turned out that 40 percent of the people who came to this meeting,
we're women and then a very large
are you all feeling and you know
a large number of them were were children are first generation immigrants who
weren't by any stretch of the imagination,
mainstream Protestant,
Caucasians,
and so the first part of the narrative fell apart and then the second part in
the air and it fell apart because it turns out that these people were getting
together to see if figuring out how they could get the damn lights together and
they're serious about it and they weren't getting their life together in a
manner that was designed to propel them in some sense to a power position.
In an arbitrary dominance hierarchy.
They were trying to get their lives together so that they can be better as
individuals so that they can be better for their families.
So they could be better.
For their communities and they were actually serious about it and in an age
where everyone is cynical about everything,
it's really something to know that there are people who are not cynical about
things that are that important and so it was a pleasant surprise to see this
article published in the same magazine that had played tricks with what I had
been doing before and I'm hoping that that will continue because it would be a
lovely thing if it did.
I know from talking to people who come to events like this that know some of you
were here primarily for political reasons,
but.
And that's fine because there's a.
it's not like the political realm is irrelevant instance.
It's by no means irrelevant,
but I know that most of the people who come to these talks comp because because
we're trying to do something about putting our individual lives together and so
and that's the right thing to do as far as I'm concerned is the right level.
Thank.
Thanks.
So I'm going to talk to you about my 12 rules for life is about but more about
the ideas in the book.
Then the book itself,
and I'm always working on the ideas and so I use these talks as an opportunity
to further my thinking along the different lines that I'm attempting to thinking
to make the story that I'm telling more and more coherent and more communicable
and so I'll start with that.
I'll start with rule one.
Rule One,
his stand up straight with your shoulders back and it contains the,
I suppose,
infamous commentary on crustaceans and trying to make a point and I should point
out because I was making a point that should actually be of great interest to
people on the left and the people on the left are of course concerned with the
distance house and that's why you need a left wing into your political structure
because someone needs to be concerned with his house.
But what point did I was trying to make in the first chapter was
hierarchies are inevitable and the fact that they're inevitability is evidence
in the existence of hierarchies in domains of life.
Far outside of the human domain.
The hierarchies have been around for $30 billion a year and there are permanent
structural elements of existence.
That doesn't mean I was justifying.
We get something that exists.
It's not going to justify it.
You took point on fit.
It exists now where the hierarchies is it completely separate issue in public
dressed very briefly in a moment,
but
there's a moral,
there's a lesson to be derived from the fact that hierarchies are ancient and
that is if you're a critic of hierarchies and there are negative consequences,
you cannot lay here existence at the feet of western civilization or capitalism
or the free market or the patriarchy because it's western civilization.
Capitalism,
the free market and the patriarchy,
which is a word by the way,
didn't give rise to hire a consultant.
And you could tell that because monsters have,
right?
So there's a third of a billion years of social labs organization into
hierarchies and you can put that at the feet of,
um,
political economic system period.
And so it's for that reason,
among many,
many,
many other reasons.
The says are wrong.
You're not wrong.
They're wrong in a way that it's going to make it impossible for well oriented
business who were actually concerned about the desert is acid,
let's say the struggling working class to actually make more headway in their
attempts to deal with the district capacity because their underlying theory is
wrong and it's wrong because it's not serious.
You know,
like I don't talk to you a slave.
The reason for hierarchies isn't a negative consequences,
so we'll go through this quite quickly.
So here's a truism.
Need something to do with your life.
It's worthwhile.
You need something to email and it's a deep true.
Is it because the creatures of it couldn't move roughly speaking,
need something Neymat.
Every creature that moves in the world that isn't statically place,
like a plant has to aim for something and generally they infer an improvement in
their condition.
So every living creature that moves lived in a value lives in a value structure
and the value structure or something like where they are isn't as good as where
they're going to.
And so there's a Knoxville good.
That's where you are and there's a bedroom which is where you're heading,
that's a value structure and you look at the world through value structure.
You would happen to value structure,
but assuming that you're actually going to move in the world and you need to
move into the world and the reason you need to move in the world is because if
you just stay in one place that you've died terribly,
so it's not optional to move forward in the world.
It's.
It's necessary.
It's necessary psychophysiologic lane and it's necessary psychologically as well
because it turns out that the way that people derive most of their positive
emotion,
which is the antidote to the suffering that's it taken to life,
is by naming something worth attaining.
That's where the meaning comes from.
Now,
the problem with naming and something worth updating,
especially if you do that in a social environment,
is that you immediately set up a competitive under corporate plans.
We'll call it the competitive landscape for them,
for the time being.
Because no matter what it is that you're aiming at doing,
if you're going to do it with other people,
some people are going to be better at it than other people and it doesn't
matter.
It can be something as benign.
Let's say it's going to have a massage.
Massage is something that you think is good and then that's a service that's
offered in your city.
Then there's going to be a hierarchical rank ordering of people who are good at
being massage therapists and running their businesses and it's not because
they're more powerful or because they're oppressing the other massage
therapists.
It isn't that even though some of them might be somewhat crooked in their
business events and maybe somewhat underhanded,
no,
it's something that's massage therapists are generally known for.
When you take the critique of capitalism and you make it,
make it specific in that matter,
you start to see how absurd it is to assume that the only reason that people
attain prominence in the discipline is because of a tyrannical power and
oppression.
It's like,
yeah,
that's part of it because every system is imperfect,
but mostly it's a matter of the mere fact that once you caught them that
something's worth doing,
you immediately produced a hierarchy.
Now what generally happens is the right way,
roughly speaking,
supports and promotes the structure of the hierarchy.
He says that's a good thing and the lab says,
wait a second.
As soon as you make a hierarchy,
people stack up at the bottom and that's not good.
You have to do something about that and fair enough.
You do have to do something about that,
but that doesn't mean that you get to put the reason for the hierarchy at the
fee up,
the social structure that you have to happen.
Now,
the other proposition I lean forward in one,
which has also been subject to,
I would say ill informed critique is the idea that there's a hierarchy and then
what you do is make yourself powerful so you can find a heart,
but that's what I said.
It's not what I meant.
You will be thinking about if you think that the only reason for hierarchies is
brute force,
because if the only reason for hierarchies,
brute force and obviously what you need to be is more of a decline in the
hierarchy,
but that is the case because well structured hierarchies aren't based on power.
Tyrannical,
pathological hierarchies are based on power and not only in the human world,
but also in the animal world.
So this is another truth that transcends the mere merely socio-cultural.
What I've been suggesting to rule one was the most effective way of orienting
yourself within a hierarchy isn't power.
It's competence and its competence of a very peculiar short.
So he might say,
well no,
there isn't just managing.
You're about to be born and you didn't know where you were going to be born and
you want it to have the right characteristics to seek.
See wherever you landed.
And so you could say,
well,
there's a very large set of possible hierarchies that you could end up in and
you want to be armed with the right properties to navigate them on average,
the most effective way.
And I think that our religious stories have evolved,
the some of our stories have evolved to provide guidelines about how you would
act if you were trying to optimize their performance across the seven possible
hierarchies.
And it isn't exactly what you'd expect.
It's not brute force.
It's something like,
well,
I said it's something like stand up straight with your shoulders back at
something like an attitude towards the world.
And that attitude towards the world is one of courageous confrontation of what
is coming at you.
And the posture is part of that because this is a defensive crouch,
right?
This is a defeated posture and that's not an effective way of negotiating
hierarchies parked because it's,
it's,
it's a shying away from the world.
And I understand that people have reason to shut away from the world.
I'm perfectly aware of that,
but that's not the point.
The point is is that if you,
if you want to optimize the probability that your life will turn out well,
you,
you absorber the catastrophe and you stand up straight and you make yourself
vulnerable because that's part of what you do when you stand up straight because
you're exposing yourself to the world and you take on the catastrophe and the
responsibility that goes along with it and that's by no means the same as
becoming the most powerful person you can so you can thrash the competition and
struggle.
You're waiting to talk in a power oriented,
dominant,
tired that's not on the same story,
but the people who are reading that who are attempting to criticize me only see
the world through that lens and so when they read something about about
alternative pathways to success,
which would be accepting responsibility and also accepting your own
vulnerability and also accepting the catastrophe of tragedy.
You've lightened again,
read it any other way that well,
he must be trying to train many targets like,
no,
that's just not right.
It's thing isn't even close to what I,
what I wrote or what have you been attempting to communicate with people.
So that's one.
So rule two and three I'm going to talk about at the same time to rule two is
treat yourself like you're someone you're responsible for helping.
And rule three is make friends with the people who want the best for you.
And those kind of make a set.
I would say,
you know,
the other comment that people who've been credit structuring my writing say
have,
have put forward,
I'm not complaining about this,
I'm merely observing it,
is that the rules are self evident and it's like,
well,
it's not like I didn't know that when I wrote
my point point,
my whole point was to take things that were true is in the sand and think about
truisms is that they're actually true.
That's the thing,
you know,
they're universally accepted.
Their proverbial let's say,
but that doesn't mean we don't forget why they're true or the or the now and
then because they're true,
they fallen on deaf ears and you need to go reinvestigate the structures
underneath that.
Make them true so that you can understand that so that you can see them with new
eyes and so that's what I was trying to do and say,
look what these things are.
The reasons that these things happened to be the case to to treat yourself like
you have someone responsible for helping,
you know,
that's actually not a simple thing because it isn't exactly self evident that
people liked themselves.
No,
I mean there's some people you like and something that you disliked.
That's generally the case and some people just like almost everyone and some
people like mobiles never went.
It's a temperamental issue,
but as you might think,
well people are basically narcissistic and they liked themselves better than
they like anyone else and I don't think that's the case.
It's not been.
My experience with people certainly hasn't been my clinical experiences.
My experience has been that because people are more aware because individuals
are more aware of their own flaws,
that then they are aware of the flaws of anyone else excluding the narcissists.
They actually tend to be pretty damn hard on themselves.
I opened chapter two by describing the fact that the typical person,
if a typical person takes their dog to a vet and the vet prescribes the
medication,
the typical person will give their dog of the medication,
but if they go to a doctor and get a medication,
then the third of them won't fill the prescription and half of the remaining
third won't take your prescription and you might think,
well that's just carelessness.
It's like,
well,
no,
it's not because you,
you,
you're,
you won't do that for your dog.
And then one of the conclusions you can draw from that and said people actually
like their dog more than they like themselves.
And I actually think that's generally true.
You know,
people are pretty wholeheartedly affectionate white would they have a dog
otherwise?
Right?
But their whole heartedly affectionate with the dog.
It's just a damn dog.
And if there's anything wrong with dogs,
that doesn't mean they would extend the season itself.
And I think what you're producing is it is a,
an explanation of why that's a bad idea.
It's a bad idea not to treat yourself property.
And so the idea is that perhaps you have a moral obligation to treat yourself
properly as if you or someone you were responsible for helping,
you might take more.
What's the right frame of mind for that?
That I can say,
well,
imagine if you have a child who's wellbeing,
you are actually responsible for it.
It's not that hard to imagine now in and then you're the appropriate thing for
you to do as a civilized and responsible human being is to do everything you can
to help that child to encourage the child because that's.
That's the right phrase.
If you had to boil down what you should do with the child into one word
encourages a really good work and to encourage the child is to instill in them
that sense that they're fundamentally.
It's a fundamentally worthwhile endeavor for them to take their proper place in
the world and also to recognize both implicitly and explicitly that there is
something that the child brings to the world that only that child and bring into
the world would be a lesser place without it.
And that's really what it means to have faith in someone.
And it's necessary to have that sort of faith in yourself and,
and I need an ID detached way.
It's in the same way that maybe the presumption of innocence would apply to you,
which is a good thing to know innocent before proven guilty.
It's a lovely rule of thumb and the idea that because human beings have
intrinsic value,
which is the cornerstone of our entire social system,
our legal system,
our economic system,
it's the fundamental cornerstone that the same thing applies to you.
It doesn't really matter whether you lightened yourself or not.
That's not the point.
The point is that independent of your knowledge of your own flaws,
which are no don't matter for you,
have a responsibility to do everything you can so that the basket you can
flourish in the best possible way in the world.
And so that's what chapter two is about in chapter three is an extension of that
to the social world.
I could've written it.
See,
there's this psychologist named Carl Rogers who I really like and Rogers has
written some great things which I'll refer to later on,
listening to really,
really practical advice and practical advice.
It's hard to become point right because most things are so abstracted life that
you can't just can't and you like a guidebook and say,
well,
follow this and it's gonna work out,
but Rogers has done a nice job with that with regards to listening and I'll tell
you about that later,
but Roger said that you should have unconditional positive regard for your
clients if you're a therapist.
I never really liked that.
I always thought there was and behavioral analysis of Carl Rogers interactions
with his clients indicated that he did follow that dictate
or Oregon or that it was an insufficiently sophisticated articulation of what he
was actually doing.
Which is a better way of thinking about when clients come to see me.
What I think is I'm on the side of the part of you that wants the best for you
and I have not at all on the side of you that wants death,
destruction and or.
And there's definitely a part of you and that leads in that direction,
and sometimes the snowbird,
well,
we parked.
That's the part that these you to do sell both destructive,
despicable,
reprehensible things or at least to contemplate doing that,
but also to do the like,
let's make no mistake about that.
And so I would say that you want to make friends and this is a moral obligation.
Again,
it goes along with the idea that there's something about you that's
intrinsically valuable,
that you have a responsibility to act property to,
towards independently of your feelings about yourself.
It's the same.
The same thing occurs when it comes to surrounding yourself with people in your
life.
You should be.
You should take to yourself the right to choose the people around you,
your friends,
let's say who are happy,
when good things have happened to you,
genuinely happy and unhappy with bad things happen to you who are actually on
your side.
And if you have people around you that aren't like that,
then you should seriously consider stepping away from them because you putting
up with the fact that they're not like that is not in their best interests
either.
All you're doing is facilitating.
They're acting in the world.
Have an attitude that's not good for them and not good for you and you might
drink well.
That's kind of harsh to walk away from people just because they don't treat you
well.
I would say,
well not the first time.
They don't treat you well or not.
When it's when it's you know,
no one's perfect.
There's going to be bumps and hills and dips and every relationship.
That's not my point,
but you know perfectly well the difference between someone who's actually on
your site despite their faults and someone who who really isn't in that,
in that latter category with people would be people who are pretty happy when
you fail or don't even try because they're failing and not trying at.
If you're doing it too,
it's a hell of a lot easier on them and that's not a helpful situation and it's
an extraordinarily common situation.
It's even common within families.
You know,
I've seen plenty of situations where someone within a very dysfunctional family
starts to try to put together,
you know,
in the small ways that they initially started at all they face from their family
members is unbelievable.
Bitter opposition to any viewed as arrogant attempt on the part of the person
who's suffering to try to make things well.
The little of that goes an awful long way and so well,
so itself.
Those two rules are are a a philosophical and psychological meditation on the
the ethical obligation you have,
not only to treat yourself as if you were somewhat intrinsic value and then
we'll get into what that means later,
but also to associate with people about who you feel the same way and feel and
act out the same thing in relationship to you.
It's the minimum that you should require of the people that you allow into your
life and so that's cool.
Thanks.
Aggressiveness is because
some of you,
some of you won't be able to lead this because you've been fortunate and I don't
mean privileged,
mean fortunate,
you know,
certain certainly terrible things happen,
have you,
but you have no idea how many people there are in the world who have never
contemplated the idea that they might reasonably be able to make a choice about
who they associate with in relationship to how they're being treated.
They just never figured out without some okay thing for someone to do.
You know what it's like.
I'll give you a parallel example.
Most people in my experience,
and this is people including my students at the University of Toronto,
are pretty high functioning kids.
All things considered,
they've been academically successful.
Most of them are quite hard to repeat.
The vast majority of them are children of first generation immigrants and they
have that,
you know,
that drive to succeed.
That comes along with having parents who sacrificed a hell of a lot to get you a
university and they're hoping for good things for you and all of that.
And you know,
one of the things I found with them is that despite them being in that
situation,
very few of them,
by the time they were 21 or 22 had add ever formulated anything approximating a
conscious life plan associated say with the development of their own character,
which points to a staggering shortcoming in an educational system of,
of a magnitude that absolutely can comprehensible once you start to think about
it,
but by the same token,
so they've never thought about the fact that they could craft their life in some
sense.
You know,
that they can think about their friendships and their intimate relationships in
their use of time outside of work and and,
and their,
their reactors,
the reaction temptation and how they would treat,
how they would take care of themselves mentally and physically.
There's never been a conscious.
Things are just happening to them instead of the crafting up a plan and a
strategy for their life.
And by the same token,
they have thought consciously about a strategy for their social being.
It's just never come up as an issue,
but it can come up.
And why would you not surrounding yourself with people who actually want the
best for you?
Well,
I can tell you one reason.
What
reason would you don't want to birth yourself the responsibility.
That's the underground reasons to say,
well why would he put up with people who don't want the best for you is,
well,
they don't make much of a demand on you.
Right?
So if you're just like limping along through life bitter and resentful and
you're not putting your best foot forward so to speak,
they'll forgive you for that.
But I wouldn't really that as an indication of the fact that they care for you.
I would regard that as an indication of the fact that they're looking for an
excuse to continue doing exactly the same things itself and none of that's
positive and none of it's health clinic.
Every good that has dreadful medium to longterm consequences.
So it's not a recommendation.
It's not a pathway or recommend
rule for comparing yourself to who you were yesterday instead of to whom someone
else's today.
Well,
you know,
back to the hierarchy idea.
So we've already decided.
I say,
I think this is a solid proposition that if you're going to move forward in
life,
you're going to be inside of hierarchy and the hierarchy comes with the risk of
failure and success.
And so what that means is,
and this isn't the eternal truth,
it's a mythological truth,
which is why hierarchies are represented in mythological stories,
often outside tyrants or canes or some figure of power.
You're in a hierarchy and because of that you're subject to the pressure of
success and failure and to some degree you might succeed it to some degree.
You might fail.
You know,
if you compare yourself to other people out there in the world,
especially in our hyper connected world,
it's easy to be bitter about your relative lack of success.
And I don't care a lot more dimension.
I don't care who you are.
There's someone better looking at you that you know about baby.
That's a celebrity type.
You know,
we might want to compare yourself to and,
and maybe like you're doing midland well on the whole seven dimensions of
comparison to perhaps you know,
and,
and it's easy to become better as a consequence of that.
It's an illusion in some sense though because it truly is an illusion,
like I've had people in my clinical practice,
my breakfast across the entire spectrum of human ability from people who are
sufficiently intellectually impaired and socially impaired so that it was
impossible for them to learn how to fold envelopes in a volunteer position and
the charity.
So that would be the low functional end to people who run like unbelievably
successful organizations under unbelievably difficult conditions for very long
periods of time in a very honorable man.
And so really the entire spectrum.
And one of the things I've learned from doing that is that people are bloody
complicated and just because just because they're successful at one on one
dimension doesn't mean that their lives are all rosy and perfect along every
dimension.
No,
I mean,
what are the most successful people that I dealt with?
Someone I really admired and respected who did everything he could during the
time we work together to get is moderately sized,
successful business running just as perfectly as it possibly could for his
benefit,
but also to a substantial degree for the benefit of the people that he was
training.
One of the things that people often aren't credited with if they're successful
is their desire to help other people become successful.
You know,
if you,
if you listen to the standard Marxist trope,
you'd assume that everyone who's climbed to the top about competence hierarchy
is has a baseball bat with a nail in it can anytime everybody,
anybody sticks off an arm trying to also get get up.
The rung me just nailed them with it and it's just nothing can be farther from
the truth.
You know,
the people that I've met and been really successful are so damn happy when they
can find someone else who's young,
who's competent,
who wants things to be good that they can lend to after that,
it's.
It isn't.
Even if they're doing it for altruistic reasons.
Exactly.
It's the one of the pleasures of be in a position of authority when you have
some spare capacity is that you can help other people build their lives and it's
it's
you
have any sense at all,
really shallow,
quite to a quite psychopathic degree,
that it's much more.
That's a,
that's a source of much more deep pleasure and engagement than the money that
you're making.
It's not like there's anything against money.
Money is extraordinarily useful,
but to think of that as the only,
the only motivation for,
for successful people's pursuit of their success and then to assume that that's
the only form of reward that they get from their success.
It's so bloody narrow minded and unidimensional that it almost the gardens
belief that people can,
can assume that it's like they never met anyone who was actually successful.
I certainly haven't met in a reasonable number of them.
So.
All right,
so,
so we have a problem.
There's hierarchies in.
There are people who are more successful than you on any dimension that you
could manage and you might think,
well,
how.
The problem with that is it can make you bitter and it's a real problem.
You think,
well,
the world is unfair.
It's like,
well,
if you had a sentence and if you took a particular successful person and you get
a multidimensional analysis of their life,
you find that of the seven major dimensions of life,
so intimate relationships,
family time,
use of time,
outside of work,
educational status,
health,
um,
resistance to temptation to say there might be one or two others,
but you kind of get the idea that those people who are successful are suffering
pretty dreadfully on at least one of those dimensions.
And sometimes more,
you know,
and maybe they're doing well in their business,
but they haven't extremely ill first degree relative.
And that means both many people have an extremely ill first degree relative,
right?
It's part of life or maybe they're married is shaky or maybe they have a habit
of like a drug or alcohol habit that they're having a bitch of the time I'm
dealing with.
Or they had a bad history of abuse when they were children.
There's some,
there's at least one or two things about delight,
ones that are truly tragic and often far more than one.
So when you meet these people,
you think,
oh my God,
it's absolutely a miracle that you're successful given you're stumbling forward
with it.
Again,
if you.
If you buy into the critical Marxist approach,
you think that,
well,
there was this one percent of the people who dominate everything that's good in
everything about life is absolutely rosy.
It's like they live in some sort of glass bowl paradise that the rest of us are
completely excluded from because those people exist.
It's like,
well,
if you meet people who are successful,
you think,
well,
that's actually kind of sad in some sense because what you see is the economic
success.
Although it's nothing to be trivialized and certainly beats the hell out of the
alternative.
It's.
It doesn't relatively feeble job of protecting you from the fundamental
catastrophes of like,
and that's too bad in some sense because wouldn't it be lovely if you could be
economically successful and then you were far distant from any sort of
catastrophe or tragedy,
but you're not.
Now that doesn't mean you're not from buffer and thanked me because otherwise,
why the hell would we have an economic system at all?
Right?
The whole point of the economic system is to fight for you against catastrophe.
But so,
so it's,
it's,
it's a mistake to be envious say,
because what it means is that you're,
you're looking at someone through their very narrow lens,
you're elevating them above you on that particular dimension of comparison and
you're demeaning yourself.
And so technically it's a,
it's a mistake,
which is why I think envy is a real mistake.
It's like,
what am I helping you know,
the person,
unless they have to be very,
very close to you,
you know,
what do you know about their life?
It's like,
don't,
don't lead to conclusions here.
It isn't obvious to think about you have a class on every possible dimension.
And even if they do well,
that might mean you have something to learn.
And it might also mean that they were the beneficiary of a province and fate.
I mean,
there is some element of luck in life,
right?
But with 70,
we want everyone to be unlucky.
I don't think so.
That seems like a bad solution.
And so and so and,
and,
and the other thing too is you actually want there to be people who are better
than you would think because like what the hell else are you?
What are you gonna do with their arm or you want some odd,
right?
I mean we already discussed that.
It's like you're up,
you're up the pedicle and all seven dimensions.
It's like,
well,
is your guns like,
you know,
welcome to the promise land.
Like you need people who are better than you think.
So then you have something to eat.
Now the question is,
well,
how do you,
how do you aim and improvement without calling Craig venter this?
And I would say use yourself as a control subject.
It's sort of an idea I can write from,
from being an experimental psychologist,
you know,
if you,
if you produce two groups and you and you run an experiment,
I'm going to do the experiment on one group or use the other group as a control
there.
The comparison group.
But you need a comparison group for your own project,
let's say self improvement and the question is,
well,
who the hell should you compare yourself to if you're going to improve and that
you have,
because that's the perfect comparison that the guy that was due yesterday,
exactly like you has all your privileges.
He's the same guy and so I'm so.
Whatever's holding you back,
what's holding you back?
It's the same thing and whatever opportunities are ahead of you were ahead of
him.
So you think,
well,
I can be a little bit better than he was,
and that's a group game because it allows you to accomplish because you know
there's plenty of room for self improvement,
right?
You're not going to run out of things to manage and so you get the comparison.
But it's a realistic control and this is a very powerful technique.
I learned this partly because I'm a behavioral psychologist in particular
behavioral psychologists do when you go see them,
it's quite fun to be trained this way is they take larger problems like I need
to get my life together.
I'm unhappy and miserable what I need to get my life together.
It's like,
that's way too big a problem.
You're never going to solve that problem.
That's just.
It's too big and too many than everyone else has the same problem and there's no
cure for it.
So it's
true to the point of being a true,
isn't it?
It's like,
no,
no.
We want to decompose that.
We want to differentiate that.
It's like,
exactly why are you registered miserable.
let's not have a one phrase description.
Let's talk about your fiverr page description.
What the Hell is wrong with you live at the level of details that might enable
you to actually do something about it.
And so,
you know,
one of the things I do with my clients is if they're,
if they're depressed and anxious,
the first thing they ask them,
it's like,
Whoa,
tell me about your sleep schedule.
And a very large proportion of people depressed and anxious or otherwise,
unless they're locked into a fairly rigid schedule,
have a very dysregulated sleep and wake schedule.
It's very common one,
university students for example,
so they get up at like 7:00 one day and 2:00 the next day at 3:00 the next day,
you know,
8:00 the next day,
although the 8:00 and 6:00 thinks they're rarer,
but the first thing is like,
why don't you fix that?
You'll pick a god damn time and get up like,
like a,
like a civilized person.
Why?
One of the things you want to do if you want to have a child,
like an infant that is absolutely dreadfully miserable all the time is stabilize
the time they go to bed at the time they wake up and because the child is trying
to stabilize its nervous system,
right?
Because life is very chaotic and what you're trying to do with the child is
provide some islands of stability so that the child can organize it's competence
around those islands of stability and you need to do the same thing for
yourself.
It's like if,
if things are all over the place in your life,
then you can start stabilizing and say like,
pick a time to get up.
What time?
Well,
how about a why?
Because that's what most people get to.
So here's another rule.
You should do what most people do,
unless they're special
person can't get up at eight because I'm a bleeding flaming genius at creating.
I'm inventing Toronto Equations will never say you don't have to get up at
eight,
but if you're not Michelangelo or or Einstein was doing what people do because
they have a reason for doing it and then you fit in the world a little bit and
it's also not such a bad thing to fit in the world a little bit better because
it's just easier for you for everyone else and so and then you might be okay,
so then you might take one.
I can't just all of a sudden get up at 8:00 in the morning.
I don't have the discipline.
It's okay.
No problem.
How about you get up before 10 for like three days?
It is.
Seriously.
It's like an idiot if you have a real discussion with someone about this.
You say,
look,
here's the deal.
I know it's hard for people to change the behavior.
I understand that.
And what I want you to do,
we're going to figure out a plan that will make things better for you with,
I don't want you to agree with the plan unless you agree with it,
because what the hell is that?
We're going to come up with a plan and you know perfectly well,
you're not going to implement it and you're going to tell me it's a good plan
because you're too agreeable and you want to make me happy or some bad reasons
like that.
And then we're just wasting our time.
So why don't we just assume that it's just as hard for you to change your
behavior as it is in everyone else and you're probably not going to do it.
And so don't say yes.
Anything that you don't think you would actually do.
And then that's an exercise in humility because you know,
when we tried to go to the gym three times a week and you fail.
And so like everyone or almost everyone,
and no matter how many of those resolutions you make a new year's,
you just don't do it.
You don't stop eating cake and you don't stop drinking too.
Beer,
fear and all of that.
You just keep doing so.
Okay.
It's hard to change your behavior,
so I'm going to lay out a plan with you.
We'll discuss it,
and if you think that it's a good plan that you might do then say Gif,
but otherwise say no,
what will a floor but we want to do is aim low enough so that you have a
reasonable probability of success and in our three constitute some improvement.
Now Carl Jung said,
modern people don't see God because they don't look low enough,
and that's the sort of thing that he was referring to.
It's like,
let's say you want to improve yourself.
well,
how much are you capable of,
you know,
lead from you to the Messiah one week?
No,
that's not going to happen.
Like you might be slightly better than your wretched self,
one 10th of one percent or something like that,
but it doesn't have because of the trajectory is more important than the
starting place and incremental improvements are staggeringly worthwhile.
They pumped up incredibly quickly and it's part of the reflection of this prieto
distribution issue or price's law is when you started improving things,
each time improved something.
You've the probability that the next improvement will work and so there will be
improvement.
Trajectory isn't linear.
It's like this and so if you can get the damn thing going,
which is hard,
it's hard to get those initial steps in place that can really take off if you're
consistent with it and so what it might mean the first week is if you're
sleeping schedule is completely awry.
Then you get up three days this week before 10:00 and that's like 10 percent
better than the previous week.
It's like,
yes,
you've compared yourself than you were yesterday and now you're better,
and then the next thing I ask people is like,
what do you do when you get up?
Do you eat now?
I'm not one of those people who have some breakfast to be wonderful human beings
that need to say,
why do I?
I've never.
I've never been hungry in the morning as well.
That wasn't a question.
It's like I didn't ask you if you enjoy breakfast,
that's not the point.
The point is you had to fast for 12 hours or 16 hours and now you have three
cups of coffee,
which is not a very good idea and then you load yourself cognitively and you
just regulate yourself.
Psychophysiologic Lee,
because you hyper produce insulin.
As soon as you stressed yourself,
you take all the sugar out of your blood and then you're basically screwed until
you sleep again that night.
And so if you're anxious more than you want to be and you don't eat breakfast,
you can probably get rid of 30 to 40 percent of your anxiety just by eating
breakfast and you think,
you know,
it's like,
yeah,
you have
to
think,
well,
I read it.
I don't like breakfast.
Like eggs.
Like who cares what the hell?
Like what kind of experiences
for.
Right.
When you probably develop the habit of not eating breakfast,
do you haven't revisited it since then?
So eat something that's sort of protein and fat heavy in the morning and at six
months you will start through joy it.
I thought that's a whole different issue and then just do that three days this
week and see if you feel better and if you don't,
well that,
you know I'm wrong and so much for that stupid theory,
we'll try but.
And we'll try it,
but people come back.
I had one client who was actually starving.
I mean she,
this person was,
was very nicely put together.
Twenty five year old professional woman and all she ate was like two handfuls of
rice a day and she said,
I come home and all I can do is to sort of fall over on the couch.
And I watched the same movie every night.
So like,
I don't know why any energy.
So I did a careful analysis of her sleep and eating habits and I thought,
Oh,
well you're actually starving.
That's your
things.
I really liked
that job.
It's a testament to the lack of utility of envy.
That's the first.
And it's also our encouragement to be humble enough to make small improvements
to who you are in the hopes that that will catch on and moving forward.
And I can offer you a sort of a strategy for that.
This is a nice one.
This actually,
this actually works quite well and I do lay it over to some degree in the book.
So.
So the first thing is you might take stock and think,
okay,
well what are you doing that you know,
that stupid.
It's like you can make a long list here.
Stupid things.
I know I do that.
I should stop.
It's okay,
great.
Great.
That's no problem.
You can ask yourself that question.
What stupid things do I do that make my life more wretched and few tiles that it
has to be okay?
And so,
and if you,
if you do a little meditation around that and we actually want to know,
you'll come up with a list pretty fast and it's kind of a humbling exercise,
right?
To do that.
But.
But it's worthwhile because if your life is more regimented,
few titles that people want to be,
it's possible that the reason it's like that at least in part is because you're
doing things to yourself that are good for you.
And so then there's the question that derives his therapy,
which would be,
well,
if your life is the way you want it to be and you start doing all the stupid
things you know that you're doing,
then how much better would it be?
And the answer is you don't know,
maybe it would be way better.
Maybe it would be so much better than it wouldn't be wretched and futile
anymore.
And so it might be worth that might be worth finding out,
hyperventilate.
You know,
if you don't want to just suck the stupidly it would be,
it wouldn't be worthwhile making the effort to find out.
And so
after 20 years of teaching from my wife to actually drink water,
okay,
so now you make a list of your faults and then you think,
well I got you're useful and I'm pretty bad,
but it's the.
And probably I don't do any of the things I need to do to fix any of that.
But maybe there's something on this list that I could fix that I actually would
fix.
And so that's like asking yourself again,
don't tell yourself.
It's like you're negotiating with someone who's kind of fake headed and you know
I'm very well put together and you can just tell them what to do because they're
not going to do it,
but you might go an ask them if there was something that they would do,
what it might be,
and you can do that to yourself and people have got this list.
Is there something on this list?
Is there some step I could take to address something on this list?
Then I would actually take.
Then I would have answered that almost invariably.
Yes.
I think,
well,
you know,
my,
my closet,
it's a squall of the alcohol.
I might be willing to take three of the lowest of all pieces of laundry out and
contemplate something like that.
Or maybe I have a stack of papers guess and this sort of strewn everywhere and I
don't want to do anything with them,
but I'll go in like a look at the top three pieces of paper.
That's a lot harder than you think,
man.
Because you know,
you create a stack of paper like that.
You walk into the room where that's Dr Pepper is.
You won't even look at that ball.
That's because it's full of snakes and that's how your body's responding to
snakes,
man.
Technically that is exactly what because it isn't the predatory detect is the
Predator detection circuit that kicks in,
that makes you don't look at those faces and for good reason and so if you go
there and you just,
you're like 60 percent of the way to actually doing something about them and so
you've got to negotiate with yourself and think,
okay,
well if I've got to fix myself off what in my current wretched state,
what small steps am I actually willing to take and that works.
It really works.
And that's where behavioral psychologist,
no,
it's like break the dam them down until you're willing to take a step forward on
that pathway.
If something is completely intractable that's facing you,
you know,
decomposes and he'll just keep cutting it into smaller and smaller pieces until
you finally get a piece.
You think,
Hey,
I can ask you that,
but that's also still worthwhile.
You can't be so trivial,
but you don't get any satisfaction out of it,
so okay.
That's
basically it says despite your mention present condition and your relative lack
of process,
most things you can make it like simple enough if you think about it,
so that will probably be able to make it slightly better and then you can
iterate them.
It's like that's believable.
It's not like you're jumping up and down in some sort of narcissistic way about
how great you are.
It's not that at all.
It's like you're taking your limitations and the human limitations,
right?
Because everyone's like that into account and you're actually starting to be
willing to realistically work with them and it really does work and accelerate,
so that's a good thing.
Okay,
so rural fire,
this is what I thought would be very contentious,
but it hasn't been that contentious,
which actually surprises me.
Don't let your children do anything that makes you just like,
now
I'd like to punch of fishes,
twists in it,
you know,
and one of them is just propositions nested inside of one of the children can be
dislikable.
Okay.
What will everyone knows that,
I mean when you were a child,
there were lots of children.
You get light,
right?
When you're an adult,
you have friends and they have children with and you don't like.
Some of those children is have to do less likely to invite those adults to your
house.
You won't say anything to smile with your mouth,
but not your eyes.
When the children,
that's the same style of site uses
what it's like to be a child and no one likes.
And then when they go and they see adults,
the adults smile at them with their mouth.
But Dr Rice.
It's like what sort of world is that for a child?
It's like they're surrounded by well meaning cycle house,
right?
And that's what you do to your child if you allow them to do things that make
people dislike them.
And so that is not a good thing to do to your child.
And so we've been,
first of all,
the children can be just like a whole.
And then we had met that parents can facilitate the dislike ability of their
children and we admit third that parents can dislike their children,
whose parents don't dislike her children.
It's like,
well,
first of all,
there's at least 20 percent of the people in this audience at least have not had
a very good relationship with their parents.
And so,
and you know,
families can be an absolute snake pit.
You're way more likely to be killed by a family member that a stranger like way,
way more,
like way more like,
especially if you drained with them.
So if you don't want
to be killed and don't treat them with your family,
your risk of homicide,
just stay away from your kid falls.
Okay?
So now the next
tip,
contentious proposition is that perhaps you shouldn't dislike your children.
You Think,
oh no,
that can't be possibly cute kids campus like the cat.
You should.
Here's why.
When you just like your children,
you should just like your children when they're doing things that other people
would dislike them for doing.
Because if you like the video,
then they won't learn not to do them.
And then wherever they go,
other kids won't like them and play with them and we'll facilitate their
development forward because by the time your child about you have an over most
of the responsibility for socialization to other children.
So your job as a parent is to make your child likable by other children by the
time they're in fourth.
And I can tell you this too,
if you fail at that,
they will never recover no matter what you do.
And then the experiment with clinical literature on this is painfully clear.
So kids who are alienated an antisocial by the time therefore there is no one
knows what to do about it.
None of the interventions that have been tried work,
none of them.
And believe me,
psychologist,
social scientist have been hitting this problem apart since about 19,
25.
And they've done everything you can possibly think of.
Andy in combination and a bunch of things you can think of and it hasn't worked.
And so there's a critical period of development between about the age of two and
about gauge for where you facilitate the social acceptability of your children.
And if you miss that window,
well then good luck to them.
So in what seems to happen,
here's why it happens.
So let's say you have two four year olds and their size each other up and there
because they're trying to figure out what is elemental level,
the wrap and you knew you do that with adults as you want to be with an adult
who's kind of at the same level you are to some degree if their way to hell in
Bob you with some sphere and you're not going to relate to them in that sphere
and if the way below you will the same thing.
You want someone that you can kind of contend with and so kids size each other
up.
If you're a four year old is still acting like a two year old.
Then the other four year olds will not play with him or her.
And then they will mature into five year olds and then they weren't mature.
Six year olds and then they weren't mature.
It's a seven year olds.
They'll just stay two and two that they call them the terrible twos for region
two year olds are relatively egocentric and so if the two year old you have a
child who's still to add for that,
that's that because the other kids won't scaffold their development,
so it's your job to dislike your children when they're doing things,
dislikable things.
It's your moral obligation and to correct them so that the reason you do that is
to correct them.
It's not to answer besides your authority.
It's not even to instill a sense of morality and the Indians some arbitrary and
technical way.
It's simple why you do that.
Here's what you want for your children.
You want them to have other children line up to play with them.
That's like success map and so that child is like,
they got the kind of social graces that allow them to go into an arena of
children they don't know and make friends quickly.
It's like victory,
man.
You've done 90 percent of what you have to do with imperative to manage that and
so and then,
but there's more to it to like.
One of the things I've moved and I have no kids,
I lived in a rough area in Montreal.
We have my daughter Mikayla booster board around this little cheap stroller in
this working class neighborhood in Montreal.
There's lots of rough guys,
rough people in that neighborhood,
but it was such fun to wheel around because you'd see these like rough looking
guys,
lumberjack looking guys,
you know,
a working class,
French Canadian type,
kind of tough to think like Tom Waits,
gestures walking down the street and they'd see our girl and they're stronger
and like they,
they instantly get a goofy grin like technicolor,
you know,
and it's so cool because what you see is that you have to be a pretty damned
good in human being.
Not to draw up your shell and open up a little bit when you see a young child
who's kind of open to the world and fresh.
Right?
And so you see the best people when you have kids and if you're fortunate,
and so see that's when you want for your kids,
right?
Is You want them to behave in a way that brings out the best in adults and so
when you take them out in the actual world,
the adults are happy and they will be given a chance,
you know,
because people generally quite positively to children,
unless the children are angels or do something equally,
reprehensible,
rolling door and only gets kicked because only knows this crowd.
You know that's not a good strategy and so you want your kids to be eminently
desirements with other children,
not solving massive problems right there and then you want them to be attracted
to adults.
So the bands of the sign with the adults come forward and welcomes to
continually into the world and you can actually rely on window you despite your
child because look,
we know that you have arbitrary faults and sometimes you're good.
You're good to irritate you because you're ignoring everything.
You should be right in.
They're getting on your nerves and it's your plenty trauma problems,
but what was shooting that you're 60 to 70 percent put together or something
like that.
Or maybe it's higher,
a little lower,
and maybe we can also assume that you're fortunate enough to have a partner
who's also a 60 to 70 percent put together in a slightly different way than you,
and so the two of you together might make a person the in the main is 90 percent
and not person that you made jointly is a reflection of the social world.
That's what it should be because that's what a parent is.
A parent is a reflection of the real social,
and so if you're going to do your children to favor,
then that joint when you and your partner is reflects the reality of the social
world to the child.
So the child figures out how to live in this social world.
You're not their friend.
You know?
Maybe when you're a doctor,
you can be friends hopefully you can be friends with and it's not quite your
last friend and see him way more than a friend,
right?
Way More and the child needs deep reflection of the social work.
Tampered with a bit of immersive,
right?
Because if you're a parent,
you're going to be more forgiving of your child,
then the arbitrary social world wellbeing and that doesn't mean you forgive them
everything.
It doesn't mean that at all.
It just means that the patients you're,
you're,
you're bringing them along.
That's your cool.
That's fine.
Don't
were able to map.
So you know things that you think,
oh very happy about that you think,
okay,
well maybe I can fix that.
I can help this child figure out how to do those things.
You can have them.
So my son was an ordinary little
pushing it.
It's like,
okay,
this definitely view in which you didn't like at all.
He was quite fraternity
necessity.
Kind of have a little chat with him was when he was about three and then say,
look,
you know,
you can't act like that and you can sit here and think about it and when you're
ready to be a civilized human being,
you can come and tell me and then we'll have a good day.
And so you can sit here and fix things up and have a good or you can keep doing
what you're doing.
Have a wrench in the day to make choice kid,
so we sit on the stairs or your bath mat and I drove up to them,
you know,
two minutes later and say,
look,
are you to get off both the stairs?
He,
they was drying bonus might to control his rage and these little kid and the
kids fail temper Tantrum,
so completely consumed by rage.
It's not easy to bring that under control.
And so he was sitting there like fighting with his head with his hypothalamus,
this ancient,
trying to bring it under control and then,
you know,
I'd leave him be.
And usually after about five minutes or so he'd come in.
He was more contrite.
I mean,
you know,
the attitude that we would bring to bear then was something I'd like to right
away.
It's like he was ready to be a civilized human being again and now I instantly
liked him because the rule was
once you get off the spirits and you've decided to be a civilized,
he with me then I liked him right away.
It's like I'm not going to hold a brush.
That's one of the useful things about using effective disciplinary strategies so
you don't have to hold a grudge.
It's like stuck with because it's actually done with so he'd come and say,
well,
I want to have a good day and then we'd have a good day and so we'll kind of
consequences of that was that we mostly have a date and so what a deal is a
relationship that you have.
It's probably the only relationship you've ever had in your whole life where it
can actually be almost all good if you're careful and then only parts of the
concert.
The only consequence of that is that it generalizes for other people,
so not only doesn't work for you and hopefully for your partner,
but I don't feel works for your child and other people.
So it's like,
what the hell?
That's.
That's a pretty good deal and all you have to do is have the fortitude to let
your child know in the gentlest way possible but effective manner.
Right?
Because you've never used more discipline than necessary.
It's just counterproductive how to conduct themselves in the world so that
everyone is happy with their rep and there's zero down,
zero downside to that,
except that you have to go off the responsibility of actually taking a stance in
relationship to your child's behavior and people are terrified of their
children.
Now especially,
and often we'll do that all they're willing to risk the hammer that they might
make in the discipline and there's.
It's not helpful.
So okay.
Real
Center,
Sarah House in perfect order before you criticize the world.
That's how that's the darkest chapter in the book.
I actually find it engaging to tackle dark subjects because
I've found that there's something believable about darkness.
You know,
like if someone is telling you a bunch of good things,
you think,
well,
what the hell do they know?
It's reasonable to ask that question,
but if they tell you about the really dark things,
then while you already know those dark things exist,
so it's believable and then if they're willing to sort of confront,
those are things you think,
well maybe there's something to this,
and so what are the other chapter six was,
I've tried for many decades to put myself in the shoes of people who have done
terrible things partner.
I've done that when I've read history,
which is pretty brutal thing to do,
but also when I read about criminal behavior,
especially the brutal criminal behavior,
it's not even criminals.
The wrong way of thinking about.
Because you know if a criminal robs a bank,
I think,
well they want the money.
That's sort of human.
You can relate to that,
but if someone shoots up a high school or shoots up in elementary school,
it's like calling credit just doesn't work out.
It's because a criminal once your car you want your car to so you can understand
what a criminal is.
Just your approach is different,
but you don't want to do something like that.
Young man did when he showed up at the sandy hook elementary school,
that's a whole different issue.
The question is why people do that and the reason for that,
it's outlined very briefly in rule six succinctly,
is that while it has to do with the issue of failure and the and the tragedy of
life and rule six is also a discussion of the attitude that you need to develop
in the face of the tragedy of life.
So people,
people are bound by their vulnerability and their.
They're bound by their mortality and they're liable to be trained in her.
All of those things are canonical parts of existence.
Everyone experiences them.
Sometimes it's self betrayal.
It doesn't matter.
It's still a reality of malevolence among people is a reality of the world as
this tragedy and that,
and that's true to some degree.
Even if you conduct yourself properly,
you know,
and that's the old mystery.
Why couldn't it?
Things have to get quite a bad things happen to good people,
which is a deep question.
Everyone asks themselves that question.
When things go wrong in their life,
especially when they've been trying hard to set a trap and it can turn you
against life,
and the people who do these terrible crimes so to speak,
are people who be turned against you by and in a very deep sense,
in the deepest of all possible census.
They're turned against tax.
We in a religious sense,
and I,
I can't,
I can't take the time to explain precisely why that's the proper level analysis,
but,
but to think about it to,
to,
to answer the question,
why would someone shoot a classroom full of elementary school kids?
You have people weighing me down into things.
You have to go as deep as you possibly can into the mystery of human motivation
and the catastrophe of life way down at that level.
That's essentially the level that religious language designed to.
What would you say to communicate independently of your belief in a,
in a,
in a day,
and I come,
I'm making a psychological case here.
The people who committed these terrible crimes are embittered by lights and they
believe that just because up there and bitter but perhaps just compiled was
determined to at least to some degree because there's plenty of things to be
bitter about life that it's okay for them to act as universal judge would be and
to take her revenge and that's precisely what they're doing and I attempted to
justify that because you cannot understand something until she could justify it
and then to produce a counter argument and the counterargument is yeah,
life extraordinarily difficult and people are subject to trap the tragedy of
their lives and to be trail and malevolence all of that.
And you might ask,
well why not be bitter?
And I think the answer to that is related to things we've already discussed this
to some degree.
What makes you think that you've done everything you possibly could to put
things right enough so that you're in a position to judge?
This is naturally an optimistic question and it relates to,
as I said,
the things that we discussed earlier.
There's,
there's,
there's a,
there's a building,
there's a catastrophe built into each of our lives.
The fact that life is suffering.
The question is what's the appropriate attitude in the face of that,
and I would say absolutely everything you possibly can to fit to set things
right before you dared to stand up as the judge of everything that exists as a
temptation that everyone falls prey to at our thing,
to be optimistic and that is things can be a lot better than they are and your
capacity to make things a lot better than they are is far less limited than you
might fake regardless of your starting point.
You know when people have been criticizing me because I don't take
hypothetically the fact of differential socioeconomic advantage into account,
it's like,
well,
I'm not naive.
I know that some people are born with advantages that other people aren't.
Oh,
it's complicated because advantages are multidimensional and people generally
pay a price for their gifts,
let's say,
so it's complicated,
but it doesn't matter in some sense because regardless of the conditions of your
existence,
arbitrary as they are,
your best foot forward is to try to set things right as much as you possibly
can,
and there's a.
it's,
it's and it's.
It's a courageous attitudes.
It's,
it's your willingness in some sense,
to take responsibility for the conditions of life,
for the tragedy of life and for the malevolence of life to take responsibility
for.
That's unbelievably noble task in some sense because it's really.
It's really hard to do that just because you know that you're bound by
malevolence human level.
It's in the world and you might think,
well,
that's just too terrible to bear.
It's like,
well,
yeah,
that's true.
It is,
but that's not the point.
The point is,
your best strategy is to voluntarily accepted and again to stand up for your
shoulders back to Excentra vulnerability that's associated with your big and to
do everything you possibly can do transit to accept it and transcendent and to
work with constraint.
And malevolence in the world
I know
that might not take you to heaven
and perhaps doesn't exist
and if you don't think hell exists,
then you have,
what would I say if you haven't paid enough attention to the people around you
be you haven't paid enough attention to the worst parts of your existence and
see the BBC,
you have nearly enough history.
You ready
on creativity and so if you can avoid that,
something could be something for you because you don't need that and it would be
something for everyone else because we don't need that.
And I think even if we aren't capable creative Kevin,
we might be capable avoiding.
And that would be something that would be something to take away from the 20th
century now,
wouldn't it?
Because we generated plenty of hell during the 20th century if we want it to be.
We could wake up enough now in the aftermath of all that and fake.
Okay.
How about we don't do that again?
I don't think it's an economic issue.
I think it's an ethical issue
of reading the causal pathways that lead to the horrors of Auschwitz.
Let's say reprehensible horse of a radical African places like start with this
union.
The reason that those situations became plausible was because of the failings of
the individuals who made up the society.
You can't blame it on the leader.
You can't blame it on economic conditions.
None of that.
It was that people consistently made the wrong choice at an individual level and
most profound commentators on those situations.
Viktor Frankl,
for example,
how your social,
it's all fake.
It was the willingness of the average citizen to falsify their own experiences
in the service of ideological totalitarianism that turned into two countries
into help.
It was the lies that people told that they were telling me so well that would
lead us to rule eight.
I'll skip rule seven for now.
Tell the truth,
and I think I'll probably have with this one.
I'm
too
old.
You favorite
story.
This is
the greatest story.
So,
um,
I,
I did a series of lectures last year on genesis friend and they were
psychological lectures or psychological analysis of Genesis says I was trying to
move into the theological domain content.
I don't,
it's not that I don't think that that's a relevant domain and I'm not trying to
deny the existence or or,
or speak for the existence of anything metaphysical.
I'm not trying to do that to people who do that.
It's fine and it maybe it needs to be done,
but I'm trying to do that.
I'm trying to make sense out of these.
Stuart's now.
My sense is that our deep stories are myth,
which,
which are everywhere.
By the way,
that not only encapsulated the biblical stories.
You guys all go to movies,
you go watch the marvel superheros.
You don't think that's an anthology.
It's just because we don't know anything about mythology.
It's like that's what it is.
You know,
when you watch Harry Potter,
here's what you watch.
You Watch,
you watch a diamond resurrected,
erode defeated fig figure of evil.
That's the Harry Potter story,
so and it makes sense to you and your kids read it and it generates millions of
dollars.
It's like,
well,
why?
Well,
it's because it's true.
Now how it's true,
that's complicated.
That's a whole different can of worms,
let's say,
but,
but it's,
you see it as well.
The director resurrecting hero,
redeemed his father and becomes the genuine individual.
When you go watch that with your kids,
you think,
well,
that's right and you don't care that,
no,
it's a puppet.
And then he goes and rescues his father from a whale and then none of that makes
sense that there's a blue farian talked to my cricket.
You don't care about any of that.
It's like,
oh yeah,
that's no problem.
I can see how that would work
because you have a mythological imagination and it's,
it's your thought is embedded inside that mythological imagination in the data
and that I think are essentially crystal clear.
So.
Okay,
so let me tell you a story.
So the fundamental mythological world is something like this,
something like this,
and you're,
you're specialized neurologically to operate in this world,
and so part of the world is chaotic domain.
That's why I call my book an antidote to chaos.
The chaotic moon beam is the place that you are when you don't know what's going
on,
but it's a place of potential.
It's.
You can think about it.
Let's see.
It's hard to explain this quickly.
Here's the way you're thinking about this is this is how I think people work.
This is how I think that you can understand the role of consciousness in the
world,
so I think that we're not driven in a deterministic way.
The way that materialistic entities are hypothetically driven.
Okay.
I think this is what happens in step.
I think that each of us is a locus of consciousness.
We started the act like we are in the treat each other like we are and we assume
that we are so I'm just going to assume that that's the case and what
consciousness does not fall prey to the deterministic machinations up.
It's materials don't substrate,
but the face,
the potential of the future,
and to make decisions about which of those potentials are going to realize
themselves.
So when these make.
When you think about how you think you are like,
well,
the way you think you are is that you get up in the morning and there's a bunch
of potential things that are arrayed themselves in front of you and then you
decide which of those makes or you're going to do and which of those things
you're going to call them into being an and you assume that other people do that
and if they don't do that,
you actually get angry at because you'd say to your wife,
say,
he said,
well,
you said you were going to do such and such,
which means to manifest a certain kind of potential and bring them up to a
certain reality and you get what's wrong with you.
And she'll say,
well,
you know,
maybe she'll tell you a reason or maybe she'll say,
well that.
Sorry,
because I know that you were relying on me.
And so you treat people like that.
So there's a domain of potential that's chaos and there's a domain of mortar and
that's what the chaos is transformed into when you interact with it.
Okay?
So those are the domains.
Now,
here's what happens at the beginning of genesis in our most fundamental creation
story,
the most fundamental gracious towards the West.
You have these three domains.
You have the potential.
It's the chaos that goes on two fronts at the beginning of time and whatever God
is going to think about him as the spirit of consciousness for the sake of
argument,
he uses logos to interact with potential and to create a habit in order for.
That's Jeff.
That's the first part of Genesis,
and so what happens is God speaks and potential rearranges itself into order and
then go and says,
well,
that order is good.
Okay,
so there's an ethical proposition there too.
It's a very deep proposition,
and here's,
here's something to think about.
The proposition is that if you confront protection with the truth,
that the order you generate is good.
It's a proposition.
You think,
well,
he's being good.
While it's a hard question because it's full of tragedy and malevolence like,
is it good?
If that's a hard question,
well,
without the malevolence it might be a lot better.
So that's something and fair bit of that is generated as a consequence of
deceit,
as a consequence of deviation from the truth.
So you might ask yourself,
well,
how would things be if people did nothing but tell the truth and that
proposition is inhibited.
Genesis is thing that it would be good.
And that's,
that's reasonable hypothesis because you know,
when I've worked with my clients,
for example,
for all of these steps,
what I see is it the people that were hurt the worst aren't hurt because
something terrible happened to them.
It's not cancer,
it's not an earthquake,
it's not an academic,
it's that somebody to them with attending.
And if you look at the literature on posttraumatic stress disorder,
it's quite clear that what really breaks people,
his betrayal and deceit on the partner of someone they trust.
And that might be to the south,
you know,
you can do that too.
So that's no problem that happens.
So it's not a tragedy into the World Pacific catastrophe,
even though it is a catastrophe,
it's the level of the world that's a catastrophe.
And that's probably see.
And so the second part of Genesis has another hypothesis embedded in it,
and now that man and woman are made in the but you've gone.
The question is,
well,
what does that mean as far as I can tell them?
What it means is if on the largest possible scale what's happening to generate
the world is the Kale and consciousness is interacting with potential to
generate order.
Then that's reflected in the house at a smaller level.
So each of us are also doing that on a scale,
you know,
individual in humans and that
requires your society to assume that you have intrinsic value.
And that's at the basis of our legal system.
It really is.
You know,
the idea that what we're all equal before the law,
whatever the hell that means you have intrinsic rights unnecessarily.
Responsibilities is predicated on the idea that there's something a little bit
so valuable,
but even the state has to keep his distance from you.
And the reason for that is because it was so special.
Even though that isn't part of the reason,
the reason he hasn't found its interferes too much with the individual than the
state itself collapses and that's true because the individual is the forest that
renews to stay and so the stage is stay the hell away from them individually
doesn't.
Let's say it was free speech isn't because I'm a defender of free speed.
It's because I know you haven't divine obligation to speak your truth in the
world,
so that transforms itself into the order that isn't good and then no one has the
right to interfere with that period,
no matter
Humboldt chapter as well.
In the spirit of improvement,
I could say,
well,
don't I can say tell the truth.
It's like,
well,
yeah,
what the hell you know,
and what do I know?
It looks like we're all making urine to a degree that's almost indeterminable.
And so what do you know about telling the truth?
Well,
no,
because you don't know enough to tell the truth,
but,
but maybe you could stumble towards the truth.
And so that's the message of Chapter Eight will tell the truth,
or at least don't lie,
because I could say,
and I look,
I think,
I don't believe that there's a person in this room
who
wouldn't
feel in their heart the truth of this proposition.
There are things that you say sometimes that you know to be true and you can
feel that.
I mean sometimes you don't know.
You just don't know what the hell you're talking about.
You can't tell if it's true or false or whatever.
You just here to Hampton or chaotic or ignorant or whatever.
You just can't tell.
I'm not talking about the times when you might be an error and don't go it.
I'm talking about the times when you actually say something that you know to be
false and you say it.
Then the question is,
why do you say it?
Well,
part of it is you want to get your way and achieved map.
You don't want to do the work that's necessary to get what you need in the way
that you shouldn't get.
If you want to take the shortcut.
Okay,
well that's not very bright because there's no shortcuts in reality and there's
a real,
a really remarkable spirit underlying that which is an arrogant spirit which
believes that somehow you have the capacity to bend the structure of reality to
favor you in a false manner and that that will actually work.
It's like that won't work.
It's not gonna work.
You can't do that.
It isn't gonna happen.
So but the.
But there's an arrogance underlying that misuse of language that's predicated on
the proposition that you actually have that power.
I think that through.
It's so.
It's so unlikely is it?
That would be the case that I,
that anybody clearheaded who actually thought that through and sees believing a
fairly rapidly,
so
true,
and you know what's wrong too.
And so what chapter eight is,
it's another question along the lines of incremental improvement.
Try not to say things that you know to be true.
The lie stopped going and see what happens
and then you're stumbling towards the truth and if it is the case,
as our deepest stories indicate that,
that,
that the,
that the order that is good to end,
habitable is established by truth.
Then if you start whining and order that you bring into being from the potential
that you can front will be the best possible order.
It's a,
it's a.
it's an element of faith.
It's the most profound faith.
The idea would be at risk.
You have to take an existential risk because there's no proving it beforehand.
You have to act out the proposition that the world that you bring into being as
a of align yourself with truth is the best of all possible worlds would say
we'll make the experiment to find out because I think you already know.
I think everyone knows this,
that the world you bring into being as a consequence of deceit is definitely not
the world that you wanted would have and certainly not world you want.
If everyone is doing that because the world you would have been,
if everyone is doing that is hell,
and if you do hit with hail,
let's say thinking about East Germany,
right?
So here's the situation in East Germany before the wall fell down,
if you live in east Germany,
onenote was three people was acting as a government informer to regroup.
So what that means is if you had a family of six people,
two people in your family were willing to do the government.
They were actively engaged in that process.
And if you don't think that that's healthy and you don't know anything about
East Germany because that was magnified,
say across the entire Soviet Union,
it was a 25,
30 million people by deadly.
They were dance school fraction of the people who were brutalized and destroyed
by that system.
So it's actually this chapter because I think that's so interesting is that if
you look hard enough at the darkness,
you start to see the light.
Because if you look hard enough at the darkness,
you start to see what the opposite of the darkness.
And then it's easier to see the darkness.
In some sense it's even easier to believe in it.
But if you see it clearly enough and you're thinking,
well,
whatever the light is is it's as far away from that as you can get.
And when you see the Great Totalitarian Society from the Twentieth Century were
fundamentally predicated upon the lie.
Then after go to that support and clear stop line,
someone should mention Sandra,
one starts lying can bring down a tyranny and you're thinking,
well,
that can't possibly be true.
It's like I wouldn't be so sure about that.
Like the truth,
if the truth is a lie,
reality itself,
and what makes you think it's stackable.
It's not like reality is if you align yourself with the truth that you ever
reality behind,
you know,
if you're having trouble
in your corner as probably a good idea
of the things that you're just in an articulate manner in the west,
unabashed admirer of Western civilization,
despite
harbor pop are rapidly bringing to everywhere in the world and saying,
going for that.
And I say 10 minutes for that is clear.
Now that doesn't mean we don't have our problems and now doesn't mean we should
know about it because it's not like we all generated western civilization.
It was there before it goes to the board,
so there's a lot of,
well,
what do I see as possibilities?
I see unfolding in front of us a world that rapidly improving,
we're,
we're becoming rapidly,
insanely technologically powerful,
and it's a place of unbelievable possibility and potential catastrophe and I
think what we want to ride this through property and how do we do it,
what we don't know,
because there's going to be a lot of unknowns that come along with it and so
what are we gonna do about that?
Since we don't know what to do about what's unreal with and that's what that is.
We want to build ourselves as individuals and to people who are capable of
dealing with the unknown as it manifests itself,
and that's for life is about the book I wrote before which is coming out in
audio version on the twelfth.
It's
totalitarianism,
malevolence of evil in the world.
And my conclusion was get your act together.
Fundamentally,
it's like there's way more to you than you think for good or evil,
way more had you ever forced to be contended with and in some real sense of
you're at the center of the world and that the dance the world on your shoulders
and it's determined by the choices that you make and that's true for all of us
and that's why we have intrinsic value and that's where the legal system
recognizes that and I believe it's as true as if anything can be true and I do
think it would be a good idea if we could consciously realize that.
I think we're at a point where we could normally have these stories,
but we can understand what it would mean in transformation in consciousness in
some sense,
and it kind of maturation that in some sense it hasn't been possible before now
and so my hope for the best thing that you could possibly hope for it because
why the hell no,
and so that's the most thing that I could possibly hope for it.
I think that we're capable of doing it.
I truly do believe that and so that's all I have to say about that.
That's all I to say about
talk literally for the first hour and a half and when he said I'm going to end
with this and the entire room,
I didn't really think about what's going on in your guys.
Thinking about what you just heard here for the last two hours to thinking about
what you heard,
if anything about what was on CNN for the last two hours
talking about porn star.
Okay.
The point is we're waiting.
We're finally waiting.
Guys.
I hope you could feel it
happening.
All Jordan usually just takes a moment to just create that as neck.
I think he's probably ready.
We took questions on slido.
You guys send us the questions ready?
We do this totally uncensored,
so give him around her claws.
Jordan.
Today.
We've been doing it the other way and
see what happened.
You didn't go into beyond the root risks is side of the state.
We got a ton of great stuff here.
Again,
this is completely uncensored.
People are all asking about you guys tonight.
I will start with clearly what seems to be the most important one.
When will you be doing a new web with Kanye West?
I don't think you want to hear her.
Say,
look,
anyone who's ever heard me say finger,
I think I kind of wanted to have.
What do you think about understanding thrown in bonus one for me here.
What do you think about this feeling?
Feeling in the room,
like the truth,
the joy that's in this room right here about this.
What do you.
What do you love about
this whole intellectual start?
Web intake is completely surreal moment and there's this group of people who
have risen to a kind of strange,
somewhat countercultural position of prominence and there isn't anything about
the same except they're all,
you know.
That's about as part of the job.
Thinking about what might unite them to the degree that that's a reasonable
proposition and I think what it is is that they actually have respect for their
audience and
my sense is people.
I never lecture down.
I'm not trying to make things simpler.
I'm trying to make them as,
I'm trying to communicate them as clearly as I possibly count,
but I'm making the assumption that everyone is on board and we're going in the
same direction,
you know,
and I think that that's a characteristic and everyone in that group,
like if you look out,
oh,
Shapiro's,
like that.
These are people in very different political perspectives like Ben Shapiro and
one on for example.
It's like they're,
they're pretty much on Daniel for political distribution,
but they,
they both assumed that the people that are talking to have enough sense to know
just that the people that are talking to are intelligent and awkward.
And so when I come in and talk to a group like this,
I think are,
I'm
assuming that the best way mean is talking to the best in you.
And that would be great.
Thank you.
I like this one.
If you were to write a work of fiction,
what would it be about?
Oh,
I started reading fiction.
It doesn't work,
you'd expect.
And so really the brutal satirical murder registering
as funny.
It's pretty dark
for shocking.
Um,
I only wrote about,
I wrote about 25 pages of it and are already having fun with,
it was kind of a satirical new,
our effective novel.
And then I ran into my inlaws at Christmas one year.
I kind of forget what I'm like,
you know,
because I've used it to me,
I read it to my father in law and my brother in law and my brother loves pretty
straight guy and the conservative guy and in this sort of western Alberta,
Texas type tradition,
and Ooh,
it's a brutally satirical piece.
And I read it in like,
all that happened was that there was a lot of silence.
Well,
so I think that's what happened.
If I wrote a piece of fiction,
I think that that's what's already happened.
So I don't know if it's a good idea,
but you never know.
I might finish it sometime.
I did enjoy
this theme has been sort of an ongoing one that had all the shows that you
foresee a way for the Cultural Marxists and the length is to be defeated in our
culture without violence.
Well,
hopefully not precisely defeated.
I don't think it's the right terminology.
I think that the,
I think the person who tells the best story wins.
So that's the way forward is.
When I
went on Bill Maher while back,
it was interesting because,
well I had a conversation with,
with,
with Mara,
but my book and that went pretty well because he's kind of a free speech guy
because he's a comedian,
although he's pretty left as it is,
views and you know,
there's a bit of a tension there that he hasn't fully come to terms with.
Most people are full of contradict what people are full of contradictions,
but then at the end of the show they have this extra period that's only put on
Youtube and I was listening to the panel as you know,
thrash away trump and it's like that's amongst gay,
you know,
like anybody can do that.
And so it's just not that interesting to listen to.
It's not interesting to listen to celebrities actually have trump because there
are no more interesting than hearing anyone else do that as far as I'm
concerned.
So it's like shooting fish in a barrel.
Obviously he has some flaws,
right?
Pointing them out.
It's not an act of brilliance.
Seriously.
Definitely doesn't mean you shouldn't criticize your political leaders because
of course you should,
but what are.
There was a vitriolic undertone to the commentary that went beyond trump and I
kept thinking,
well,
I'm Canadian,
so I was kind of looking at this very sympathetic to the US.
I've lived here for seven years and I really liked the US.
I think it's an amazing place.
So remarkable.
I
was thinking,
well,
these idiot trump supporters that you guys are on about like that's 50 percent
of your nation.
It's probably people in your own family.
It certainly people that you work with,
they're actually not all stupid.
The hardest that is to believe because 50 percent of the people aren't stupid.
Besides that,
for the last four elections,
50 percent of Americans and voted Republican,
but you guys are split exactly down the middle and so what are you going to do?
Defeat half your country?
Like what?
What the hell good is that you have to live with these people.
They're quite a lot like you.
In fact,
they might be even beat you for that matter,
so then I think while it's with the radical left this too,
it's like it would be better to have them drop what they're doing and integrate
themselves back into it,
do the reasonable world and be guided in that process and I think the right way
to do that is to tell a more compelling story.
It's like forget about all that resentment and bitterness and oppression,
narrative and identity politics and racial divide and all of that,
and it's like,
yeah,
it's understandable.
There are people in the world.
We do have group identities.
Everything is divided up equally,
but that's.
That's just
no
from an identity politics perspective was so god damn dog.
I can hardly stand it.
I'm hoping it's a better story.
The story of the individual is a better story.
When were you running for prime minister of Canada
pipeline
because.
Because I don't think it's unreasonable to assume that you have a political
career in Canada if I chose to do that,
but this is pretty good.
You know,
I am a psychologist and an educated and I am primarily concerned with the
individual and I don't think that I could do both of them.
I don't think it's possible to do both.
I'm talking to a lot of politicians to Canada and in Australia and in the United
States about the idea of individual sovereignty and a both personal
responsibility,
especially for the more conservative types because they're starting to cotton
onto the fact that there's a market for that.
No,
for responsibilities,
but I think I'm far more effective doing what I'm doing now.
Then I wouldn't be if I made a lateral move into a political domain,
so I don't mind.
Thanks for the record.
I'm pretty sure if the Trudeau can do it,
you can do it.
I think of that as a compliment,
but
I did not write this one,
but what did you think of Star Wars?
Episode eight
show that.
The problem was that I have with the Star Wars Program says this shows is that
every one of them is the same movie.
It's well known that that Tom who wrote star wars,
George Lucas,
Lucas consultant with Joseph Campbell,
Joseph Campbell,
was a student of cardio exam.
There's clearly continual,
partially conscious utilization of mythological architects in movies like Star
Wars,
all the big screen in action adventure movies,
so that sort of having this logical substrate and you know,
I've always fail because a story to be great has to be a great story and if it's
a great story then it's an archetypal story.
There's no way around it.
What makes it distort so more power to the horn with types for retailing.
The great stories of.
I've noticed particularly a fan of star wars.
Having said that,
I mean I can't really argue with them
given the tremendous amount of effort that goes into raising a child.
What do you think of the state and local parenting technique?
You mean winter people should stay at home with their children.
I guess that's the question.
That's a good thing you don't
think about having kids is that,
you know,
let's say you got 90 years,
something like that and maybe having two kids,
maybe three,
but probably two is pretty much the average and so that means you have three to
six years of little kids are 48 years,
something like that.
So if you miss it,
you miss it and I would say don't miss it because anymore than you have to the
problem.
We have a little kid in about six months later you think,
oh,
I've always had this little kid because he gave me kind of accustomed to it and
then I'm going to be living for very long and you don't live very long.
Time passes.
The older you get,
the faster and palaces and your life is not long and there isn't that much to
fill it with and one of the things to fill it with as little kids and you'll
see little kids who paid you for taking care of them.
They pay you by being happier than you exist than anyone will ever be again in
your life period.
And they pay you because they're ridiculous.
The comical and playful and funny.
There's like little kids are so damn funny and I can't figure that out.
They have a sense of humor right?
From like eight months.
You can play tricks on them and they laugh and I can't figure that out.
I can't figure out how they can be so damn sophisticated before they can even
talk.
They have a good sense of humor.
They can do little things,
you know,
I'm catching onto your jokes and,
and you can play with them,
which is ridiculous.
It's something that fathers in particular do with their children,
especially rough and tumble play.
I just didn't talk about that.
It was quite a good talk.
I think it's about the importance of rough and tumble play and fathering.
And then the other thing that little kids do for you is,
you know,
you get kind of jaded as you get older.
And the reason for that is you start seeing the world.
What you start saying is your memory of the world because that was years in the
world longer,
longer.
You build up representations of the world.
And then you look at the world,
but the whole world on the headset,
you what representation to use and it's so.
It's like you're just seeing icons of your imagination that that's technically
what happens and that's why things don't fill you with a sense of wonder
constantly and there are there ways of subverting that to the world reappears in
order to regional Gloria,
one of the things that psychedelics do for people,
but generally as you
renew their perceptions,
right?
And that can happen in radically,
that can happen to appointments,
absolutely overwhelming,
but little kids have that psychedelic property because when you're around the
point,
they're so completely blown away by everything that's happening that you can
look at the world through their eyes again.
And so that takes you out of your cynicism.
And that's also a really good thing.
So I would say it's not so much.
Well,
you have a moral duty to stay home with your kids,
although you might.
That's not the point.
The point is,
what the hell do you have to do?
It's actually better than that.
You know when you think you're going to have to interrupt your career,
it's like,
well first of all,
most of you don't have careers and
jobs and more power to you,
like jobs have to be done,
but,
and then even if you do have your career,
and I know this from experience,
the probability that your career is more important than the time you spend with
your kids.
It's,
it's faddish really small and especially because you can,
with difficulty,
you can have your cake and eat it too.
You can spend lots of time with your kids and you can have your career.
So I would say man,
don't mess it,
like don't mess with because there isn't that much in life that's real and
meaningful.
And that's one thing that definitely is.
Thank you.
Actually,
you referenced Psychedelics,
the way your kind of original
maybe the next door
when we wrap this tour and then we do like a trip with Peter said,
well
are you worried about becoming a bit of a cult of personality?
Well,
anyone with any sense would worry about that.
I'm so,
you know,
there's this,
there's this scene in the life of prior
window naked,
if I remember correctly,
and he's,
he's telling all these people who are carrying his shoes and his gardens around
that they're all individuals and they all chat.
Yes,
we're all individuals
and it's a great movie and,
but I like worry about
because
I think that it encourages people to develop their individuality is actually not
the way that he started calling.
You don't mind.
Yes,
yes.
I'm serious.
What do you call it?
Tight definition and there's a bunch of things you have to do is you're going to
lead or do you have to separate people from their families and you have to tell
them that everyone outside in the cold is evil and you have to figure out a way
to extract their labor and resources from them.
You have to have a compound up in the hill.
You don't want to work to have a
well known and I'm not doing any of that old school genuinely.
I think as much as I can tell,
I have some experience.
I really am trying to encourage people to Africa.
I don't want to tell people how to live apart from the fact that patients leave
the lights that are the baskets that they can conceive,
but,
and I'm partly don't want to tell me a little device because I don't know.
One of the things I've learned is you don't want to tell people how to live
their lives because you don't want to steal their from.
That's the first thing for better or for worse,
and you don't suffer for their catastrophes no matter how well meaning advice
and also what do you know?
You don't know what's so good for this person to find out what's good for a
person.
You have to listen to them a lot because.
And they have to articulate your be to discover what their appropriate destiny
is.
And that's what I.
that's what I'm hoping that people who did I,
I really hope that that's what everyone in this room was eating.
And I think perhaps that's where you're here.
Do you perhaps to be encouraged in that?
And I don't see anything about benefits apart from the fact that,
you know,
I have a certain mode of public visibility.
I don't see that as cold,
like I just see it as a conversation about things that are important that we
should be attending to that we're all participating in.
That's how I look.
Okay.
You don't want to pass out the Koolaid like we did last night.
What do you do for fun?
Beers and hanging around with comedians.
I like,
I listen to music a lot.
I bought a car last year that I actually like.
It's an old Mercedes.
Well it's 2017,
which is normal enough to be cool,
but you know,
it's a convertible and I liked him to drive around in that and listen to really
loud music.
I
do hang around with my wife and my kids who are in their twenties now,
but we get along real well in there.
Pretty Damn funny.
And,
and uh,
my son's a good musician and I like to listen to him sing and play the guitar.
My daughter had a baby and so you're like
12.
I read a lot about my daughter and she had a brutal adolescence.
It was absolutely unbelievably unbearable and no we didn't.
We didn't think she was really going to make it to her thirties and she's
better,
so
thank
you know,
I kind of think this is.
There's something about this.
It's funny
because I've been feeling.
I've had some health problems and I seem to be recovering so accurate.
You have to go down before I come up.
Especially tonight.
I don't know what it is with you guys.
You are pretty damn positive.
Thank you.
The mood in this room is the most optimal of all the places that we've been.
Other places were quite positive for sure,
but there's something emotional level of enthusiasm and this crap that's higher
than usual.